from picks knee
I mean disne our man these two are
really starting to blend together comes
the Disney animated film that grossed a
billion dollars and finally got people
to stop talking about frozen let it go
Zootopia journey to Zootopia a place
with 12 unique ecosystems and one
generic pop song in this city that's
either an impossibly advanced paradise
where animals live together in harmony
or a palace built by our mammal
overlords in the ashes of our extinct
human world after war and famine wiped
us from the earth you know one of the to
fall in love with smart complex animal
characters and they're lazy forced pun
names
his name is Emmitt Otterton it's way
zoltán yoke weaselton mayor of hydaburg
benjamin clawhauser like judy hopps get
it could see cinemas most likable meter
maid actually cinemas only likable mean
raid because seriously meter rates are
the worst I mean come on I was only in
there for like five minutes and no you
haven't written a little ticket yet cuz
I can see your stupid little machine
right there get a real job lady
get it together man win hubs teams up
with foxy con artist Nick Wilde they'll
work together to catch more printers
than Chris Hanson and form a sort of
romance you know you love me do I know
that yes thank you that's sadly they'll
never be able to consummate not because
I'm species sister anything it's just
that nobody in this movie has any
genitals or even that you know a
butthole seriously how does anyone even
go to the bathroom in this place follow
along with this kid's film slash noir
crime thriller full of bright colors
cute characters allegories to
contemporary racial and class politics
like them oh there's a them now police
discrimination you think I'm gonna
believe a fox affirmative action mama
women clues
tokenism sir I'm not just some token
bunny sexism help are all rabbits bad
drivers or is it just you and racial
slurs bunny can call another bunny cute
but when then we'll either teach your
kid to be more tolerant or turn them
into a furry so settle in for a
fantastically animated well toad lesson
about disproving stereotypes even though
the Fox character really is sneaky the
weasels do cheat and the sloths are slow
oh wait no does this mean I'm racist I
own a bunch of rabbits when I was a kid
I mean no they were mine but not that I
you know not let their property or hope
look I love rabbits okay this that came
out all wrong good starring go to
starring starring in ypd Bluth the part
in the trailer that makes you want to
see the movie buff a Luthor bad mayor
Mufasa Shakira Shakira your
stereotypical Italian mobster your
stereotypical doughnut-eating Cobb your
stereotypical dumb southerner and hot
buzz he get it cuz he's a funny cop but
she's hot too but I can say that she's
hot though right dang it Maya racist
Anna furry now this movie is such a
minefield Paul and order let's see big
hero six wrangled record Rhino
I wonder what they think of Lion King in
the jungle book are they like
documentaries be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers hey screen junkies
San Diego Comic Con is just around the
corner
and we want you to join us there from
the most epic screen junkies Comic Con
experience of all time click the link to
sign up for a chance to win an
all-expenses-paid trip for you and a
friend to get VIP access to our first
ever comic-con mega event screen junkies
central there you'll get to see all the
exclusive programming we're cooking up
for Comic Con and meet your favorite
screen junkies personalities enter today
for your chance to win
see you at Comic Con bong bong dragons
GT is not canon I never liked reading
your comments in my super-awesome boys I
put myself to sleep with my boys I'm
just you friendly neighborhood
spider-man float like a butterfly sting
like a bee